you don't wanna okay hello everybody and
welcome back to unwaxed with your
favorite sisters
christine and sophia we look a little
matching today
we're both wearing literally the exact
same basic
shirt that's black um gold jewelry and
our hair is colored by the same color
so we and we use the same face tanner
so i don't know if um
we're now starting to morph into one the
more we hang out yeah
anyway happy new year everyone we are
here
january 2021 we made it
um i'm proud of all of you out there all
of you
it was a tough year it was a struggle
was a lot i've persevered and we're here
yeah how do you feel about it you know
my mental health
took a hard hit my body took a decline
for a hot dog your body looks good
quarantined blow up baby but
i could not be more excited for a new
year
genuinely like this was i was really
excited last year about 2020 coming
because i was like
2020. it sounds like a very cool year
like we had the back of 2020 is
i think mood boards are so cheesy right
like i i'm not about them
sophia forced me to make one for the
first year 2020.
and it got you excited about the i want
to burn it because it honestly made me
sad about it
you know i actually think the opposite i
was looking at my mood board
or vision board that i put for 2020
and i wouldn't say necessarily
everything happened but a lot of things
happened i put a podcast thing
i put building a brand i put oh i put
one i put like wild relationships which
isn't i don't have any wild ones but i
dated a lot
um the only thing that didn't happen was
travel see the funny thing is the
difference between your mood board and
mine was
like night and day i put on people
skiing
horses a slice of pizza and love
and i got none of those things except
for the pizza yeah why
because that's like not a vision board
that's right i didn't understand that
i didn't understand i want a pizza on a
horse blonde skin
one thing that also never comes true for
me is new year's resolutions
they never happen um maybe because i
forget
i say the same one every single year
i'll
eat healthier and it literally doesn't
happen
it is boring um but you know i feel like
this
year since it's now finally january
i need to have like a good resolution or
something that i will actually stick
with yeah and i think
for me it's just going to be to work
hard and really put a lot of effort into
like my career or whatever
crafting like well together yeah we're
doing the next year we have a lot of big
things coming up i have a good one i
have a good one
i want to be stronger and not let people
walk all over me
and every sense of that in terms of
men telling me off in terms of you know
people like agents or contracts or blah
blah blah
telling me what they think is best for
me no no no no no no no
i will make my own choices and you know
it is a it's a lesson i feel like a lot
of people do feel like that
when it comes to business and stuff and
i know the sustain and i have definitely
been trying to work on that more
so if you're that person who thinks that
we would naturally just have this
genocide club like telling people to oh
stay back
2021 guys start speaking up
speak for what you believe in get go for
the things you want you realize after
2020 that life is short and
life is really really fragile so get at
it
2021 here we come and
to top this all off we have
an angel on earth beautiful today's show
you guys she dropped some wisdom on wow
she we talked about everything from body
confidence to self-love
to being your own boss yeah i mean we
got so deep with this girl she is
amazing you guys you think you know this
girl
you do not she is so much more than just
the model the instagram girl that you've
seen and i've heard about since i was
literally 14 years old
she is so beautiful and we are stoked
to have her on today it is alexis friend
so stay tuned
okay i'm about to give you an incredible
intro that i can't take credit for
sophia did right thank you
but i mean the list of accomplishments
that you've done
i mean i could go on for pages but i'll
try to sum it up as best as i can
all right so what does this girl not do
she's an entrepreneur model and an
advocate for environmental protection
mental health self-love and empowerment
she is also an actress and musician
with over 14 million instagram followers
she continues to be one of the most
recognizable faces on social media
she inspires acceptance positive change
by leading with authenticity
and paving the way for what it means to
be a modern woman this
is ladies and gentlemen alexis
red yes
okay by the way i did that all in one
breath i couldn't i don't know if you
could tell but i did not breathe
how dare i ever mess up such a good
intro i mean like i
couldn't mess up what you want oh thank
you now i can breathe
well thank you so much for coming on the
show i mean you are so inspiring and
it's so
amazing that sophia i could talk to you
and hopefully have a bunch of women you
know relate to this conversation if
anyone was going to be
busy during quarantine i feel like it'd
be you yeah you made some time for us
and we really
appreciate it you want to hear something
funny is that i have heard about you
since i was like in middle school yeah
raised in l.a like southernmost
[Applause]
it's so weird like so many so many girls
are like i grew up with you i'm like
what
there's you're like i didn't grow up
with you what does that mean
it's an interesting dynamic you know
just like growing up with girls like i
have moms coming to me being like
my daughter grew up with you and now
she's in college i'm like what is your
response to that that must be weird
um it's it's really cool because
i think there's a deeper connection than
i have with my fans than just like the
usual
right has they've been able to grow with
me
and then i've also been able to just
like continuously share how i don't know
what i'm doing and we don't
know we no one knows what they're doing
i'm figuring it out together yeah
oh what does this do and we're like
totally yeah when do you think that like
you saw that
first gravitation of people towards you
like
what do you think sort of started that
um
well it was it went all the way back i'm
sure you guys remember like the tumblr
days
remember girl i'm still on it what do
you mean whatever
i got an account when you were um when
you
when we emailed you back and forth to
like have you come on that was the first
thing she said she goes
the tumblr days i see you guys the days
are still relevant what do you mean
oh gosh it went back like even before
that it was like
tumblr days and then i got scouted by
brandy melville when i was 13.
before they were like you know known
around
that was like the dream i remember
growing up that was like the dream
all i wanted to be was a brand new model
it was it was like a
it was a teenage version of kind of like
the victoria secret angel that was yeah
right yes yeah it was cool i i wanted to
so i was homeschooled so like
being scouted like that was an absolute
dream and
it's just been like a compilation of
keeping really good connections in
relationships i think that's
the most important thing is like the
level of trust that you have with the
people that you grow in
growing with the people that you know
like for instance my god sister
i really tattooed on my arm we've known
each other for like
15 years now and like myself ever
not having her in my life so like those
kinds of relationships kept me
grounded while i continued to for sure
like run around in an adult world while
i was four
yeah well that's so funny that you said
adult world because that's exactly what
i wanted to ask you about
you started modeling when you're 14 and
it is such an adult industry and
i couldn't imagine being that young and
you sometimes
feel alone and so when you're surrounded
by people that are much older than you
you gravitate towards what
they think and that what they know is
best for you did you ever feel like
you know sometimes you made certain
decisions or were told to do something
that you didn't
know what was right or wrong because you
were so young
yeah um i actually had a lot of
challenges and i guess this is a great
really good
point to make for like younger girls
listening to this be really
really really careful what you sign um
and don't undervalue yourself
like you never really be and so like
having that self belief of like i'm
worth
something yeah just sign your life away
to someone and yeah
i've done that multiple times and it's
been horrendous situations to get out of
um it's taught me a lot so then i can go
back and
help girls that are in these situations
where these people are like i'll give
you your dreams just sign this six year
contract and so like
that is what i would say was the biggest
downfall of being in an adult world
um while being a child is you want to
believe the best in people and that's
gotten me so far but at the same time
that
that innocence has also backfired
sometimes so just a hundred percent
being aware always having a lawyer on
your side
100 i mean i've been through
so many different modeling agencies so
many different acting agencies because
at the end of the day it's almost like
these people they don't really want the
best for you they want the best for them
and that's that was the bottom line it's
about money at the end of the day
just just knowing that in your heart and
then directing yourself to the people
that
um your heart is called to as opposed to
what they're saying because like yeah
this entire in any industry like it's so
much about talk
and giving that giving the relationship
time to grow so you can see what they're
actually
being and doing as opposed to just what
they're saying it's really important
not rushing that process like once you
oh my gosh like this is the person i've
been looking for to really help
me whatever it is that you're doing
don't rush into that just give it time
because these are huge decisions that's
going to affect your life 10 years yeah
and as a young girl you know we think 10
years from now it's not that
it's so far away it's like yeah i'm not
even going to be here i'm going to be
offended i'm going to transcend like i'm
not going to help you but you ha you
have to think
that's the maturity level is being like
okay what does 10 years from now
yeah what is that going to look like for
me um so having that
in mind do you think you learned those
lessons just sort of
being 14 thrown into this world and you
know you kind of have to learn how to be
a little bit street smart a little bit
scrappy and fun for yourself because
again no one else would really have your
best interest
um was there ever a story or a point or
even like a certain age where you
had this realization because the way
you're talking and thinking now is like
you've got your head on your shoulders
really right whether that's from a
person that you're close with
saying this to you saying like you know
maybe you should like watch out for this
person was there like ever a moment that
like friends or family close to you were
like
you know maybe this is the direction you
should probably look into or
yeah no i was really really lucky i had
a
strong support system whether that be my
family whether that be my sister's like
there was always
someone in the back end that was
patiently you know no one ever forced me
to make a decision um my mom was like my
biggest inspiration is to this day
she was she homeschooled me and so i
i grew up trusting my own instincts as
opposed to like
me that i had to learn them yeah she
always told me she was like you already
have everything you need so just like
trust that
and then go from that standpoint in life
um but then when um she passed away in
2015
when i was like i think i was 17 i just
turned 17.
that that kind of threw me off that
belief system because she was my anchor
to those perceptions of life and so when
she wasn't there i kind of lost that for
a little bit yeah
and that was when my family around me
was kind of like alexis like
how's your mental health doing like
what's going on this is the time when i
was traveling the world i was getting on
a flight after a flight after a flight
my health was
in bad condition i was trying to upkeep
this image that wasn't
real and it was just it was an
interesting position to be in
but what's so great about rock bottom is
like there's always an epiphany
like right there for sure like there's
that
it's a huge uh rock bottom is a huge
opportunity like it's
huge so realizing that yeah
i think that it's so beautiful and
i'm so sorry to hear about your mom but
i i think that the lessons that she
taught you i mean you can see it clear
as day right now how beautiful of a
person and well spoken that you have
become and so that's amazing that you
have someone
like that that you can account to that
that's that's wonderful and i want to
also
point out that since like we mentioned
before that i've heard about you since
middle school
you've continually been so vulnerable
and open to
everyone since day one it's almost like
you kind of
in a way pioneered the whole social
media
kind of openness to everybody because
you were one of those girls that
everyone like really looked up to
yeah you've never really strayed away
from your hardships and that's what
everyone
really connected to you for and you
still do that even more so and which is
so beautiful so we wanted to like
commend you on that because that was
um amusing that you were able to do that
because i
i think starting the show we have even a
hard time sometimes being
that um exposed and but you realize how
many people
respond to that and that's like the most
incredible feeling i mean did you get so
many responses
from i mean all of those hardships when
you opened up about like
um like dieting or your mom or even like
mental health was it just overwhelming
how much love you probably received or
yeah it is and and that's what's so cool
i think
you know when you have people who follow
you there's an opportunity for real
connection there
they do look at you as someone that is
creating a path that they want to take
that there is like essentially there and
so i wanted to build that trust as much
as possible and to be honest with you
like
i just couldn't be any other way on
social media i'm just so
i was so drained of like i was scared of
how i want i needed to be perfect and
yet i felt so
fakie 80 of the time and like to this
day i still
struggle with this i think we all do
it's just like what
at what point do we
create this line of no i'm not going to
show this part of myself because you do
not honor that nor do you see that
you guys are looking for a dopamine hit
you're not looking at a real person and
so
i think to this day i'm still struggling
with that i think i think this
we all are you know i mean i totally
agree and
i feel like someone especially in your
position because not only were you the
first one to open up as what sofia was
saying you're almost like the first
like it girl and so there's a lot of
pressure with that i mean like you were
the first
one that every girl was like i want to
be here every guy's like i want to be
with her and
people think that that's like the dream
and you want to be in that position but
just as big as you've got you also get
that amount of hate
and so on instagram i feel like it's
that works right like
it's so strange it's like the law of the
universe it's like it has to
you have the duality you don't get you
don't get it all it's so strange so
instagram is a very cruel dark evil
place the comments are not nice
do you ever sometimes dive into those
and read them or you really try to block
them out
um i try to block them out as much as i
can at this point in my life i'll post a
photo and then like turn off my phone
and i won't even look at it good for you
yeah
good i it's like you have to in your
heart right because you're like oh
this is do good and then you're like i
want to feel good today i want this dope
yeah
you know it's yeah yes yes i cut on here
or is that like oh yes oh my gosh
no and it's so it's not real it's
[ __ ] it's not right and it's so
frustrating when you post a photo that
you really wanted to post you're like oh
this is like such a beautiful moment of
like showing who i am and it's like
doesn't get that many responses i'm like
oh god and then you need to close me
that's
what continues why do i still put my
self-worth on this you're better you
feel
better like
i always test myself i'm like i'm going
to post this i know this isn't going to
do well but
does it actually [ __ ] matter it's
what you like
yeah and it's like at one point and that
was another thing like it's
this is the game of it's never enough
it's never enough always
the content it's a black hole there's
always going to be another interview
there's always going to be someone
hating it's just like it's never
enough and then it's too much and then
it's it's just it's
it's just it's it's a never-ending cycle
it's it's it's terrible and i sometimes
my mom always tells us like
don't give a [ __ ] what people think
because at the end of the day you're on
this
life no it's true it's like we're on
this life for one short amount of time
and so are you really in in 10 years
from now gonna remember what becky
commented on your instagram
saying that you don't look good no so
what's the point but what i found
interesting about instagram at least for
me i don't know if i can i can't speak
for you
was most of the hate came from other
women
yeah and i thought that was so
interesting because a lot of you know i
i see a lot on instagram like women
support women
women women you know uh empower other
women but a lot of the hate comes from
other women do you see that on your
instagram as well i do and it's it's
yeah it has its innocence within it
because yeah
it you know we talk about body shaming
we talk about wanting to point out ah
this girl like see she doesn't even look
like that in real life
it's it's helping them feel secure
within their own flaws and
i recommend that and i respect that and
if they need to like project that onto
me in order to feel safer then who am i
to judge because then if i am
saying hey hell what the hell like it's
just it's the same energy it's kind of
being like
world peace and like screaming and
yelling man it's just like ah
you got to match that you can't yeah
yeah
you've obviously overcome it and you've
like flourished and you've built such
amazing platforms and
incredible companies and we just were
reading about warriors
is this like you've done an amazing
projects like how what was your favorite
one out of all of them you've done
warriors you've done prosperity or is it
future prosperity
yeah what has been your most um
rewarding journey and experience and
growth of a
certain industry that you've created
it's always it's always been about
mental health it's always been about in
the environment and i i don't separate
the two because
because you know my friend the other day
was like well i care so much about like
the mental health like
why should i care about the environment
and i was like we are a product of our
environment like we it's it's not
crazy all these issues are not even
issues but just like
things that we overcome in this
dimension like
they're all intertwined and so i just
want to find different companies that
could like
tap into different sides of it because
it's like
like with warriors if i can help girls
raise their consciousness help girls
really come to terms with being here and
knowing that it's a miracle to be here
and cherishing that and then from that
place of gratitude they'll realize oh i
want to i want to be of health like i
want to help how can i help
we'll go over to future prosperity
here's where you can learn more
about what we're doing to the planet
about plastics about oil like how you
change your own little daily habits and
then in return karmically
like i've always noticed earth will
always take care of you if you take care
of her
so um it's just this like it's a new
beautiful cycle that people can get into
to have like abundance and prosperity
i i love the thought process behind it i
never even thought of it that way
because i i thought of
warriors and future prosperity as two
separate projects but
what i'm getting at correct me if i'm
wrong is that women
go to warriors to feel safe and
empowered and it's a
place where they can feel vulnerable and
open up and then when
they feel their best self they also want
to help others so then you go to future
prosperity and then
it's almost like a never-ending cycle of
like goodness
i didn't necessarily plan it that way it
was just my intention was so
strong about three years ago when i
started really questioning my
responsibility that i had
as being a person with so many fans
followers whatever
um and so then things just started to
intertwine beautifully and that's
great i always tell the girls like
especially in the community like
intention is everything
is everything um because it's gonna it's
gonna reflect and then
um come to flourishing in so many
different ways
so my intention was helping girls like i
never wanted a girl to feel the way i
felt like
trapped in this ideal i idea of
perfection
and yeah having this horrible weight on
her shoulders like
i didn't want girls to feel like um
especially during coded
the fact that we're at home so much um
like having a place and
that's what's so cool about warriors is
like we do these
um you i always find it funny how like
the truth is so [ __ ] cheesy
um you know like loves the answer you're
like cool yeah
okay i have all those like quotes on my
walls yeah like you feel like it's a
tumblr quote and you like one of those
eyes and to this day i still i have
mantras on my mirror
we do like with the girls like i have a
call with them we have calls all
throughout the weeks
sometimes they're um like morning
routine calls sometimes they're
oh nice yoga so it's very one-on-one
it's
very personal and we know it's amazing
and then we bring on other girls and
like the reason i wanted to bring on
other warriors other teachers was just
simply because
i'm at this point i can just assume that
most of these girls that are in my
circle
um whether they be models actresses just
influencers whatever they are
yeah are having the same weight and so
i was just like well here's a place
where you can just be you
the these girls like what you know
whatever
i teach them and so um it's really cool
we do i do a live call with the girls
every friday so we have like a couple
hundred girls on a live call with me and
we do
um different uh like mantra exercises or
we like all take
turns like writing about where we want
to be in five years and then each girl
gets like i love that i'm
gonna i'm gonna be on this next class by
the way i believe manifestation i love
all of that i believe writing out what
you want and i do think that
eventually it will come true if you let
it go into the universe like that whole
thing that
energy you put out what you give is like
it is all
balanced and it comes full circle and i
love that you work so closely with women
because i do
feel like especially right now there's
so much weight
on our shoulders and i think the only
way to really connect
someone and to get forward with someone
for a breakthrough is really that
one-on-one personalization you can't
i mean some a lot of these i think uh
websites and blogs like you can read
about it but it's really hard to put it
into your own words and actions have it
come from your heart
yeah and having a community that
encourages one another and
why haven't you got a question though
about women let me do this
um i just wanna ask about women like you
see that there's a lot of obviously
everyone has their own
struggles and things that they focus on
that they're worried about or
it's a lot of weight on their shoulders
what do you think is the most
common trend between all the women is it
involving
their body image is it involving their
relationships with their
like parents or their boyfriends or
girlfriends or
it comes down to um it's not so much the
story
um i think it comes down to us not
letting ourselves process these emotions
what i found really interesting is like
we are all we all have the same feelings
and then we all have different stories
attached to those feelings but it's the
fact that
we haven't let ourselves felt those
feelings that's where the trauma is
stored
and so if we can have a girl come up and
and we had this one exercise last week
where
you talked to whatever it is that you
deal with so like
my anxiety i'd be like is that me like
why are you here anxiety because
blah blah blah and like we like wrote
like a conversation
and like some of these girls just like
i mean we cry every call but like these
girls up to
such inner realizations of the trauma
that they've been holding
um as soon as they were crying and we
were all like sending them love and like
we were all on that call
um just supporting them they
looked lighter like they looked she was
like they've never felt so light
do you sometimes think that because
you're helping
so many young women out there clearly
you could see it on their faces how much
you're helping them
do you wish that you had something like
warriors growing up
yeah i mean i was so i was just like
once again i'll just like go back to my
mom like she was
literally that i feel like i'm just she
was your warrior yeah
like i was i'm just embodying like who
she was to me
for like that's all i'm doing and so i
almost feel like it's not even me doing
it i feel like it's my mom like she just
yeah whenever i like talk to these girls
and i have a question
yeah for my i need help for me because
sophia is
she is like a ball of my notebook you're
like i am your therapist here we go
um sophia has always been very in touch
with her emotions so she feels
everything i feel everything but i don't
let it out and i
keep everything bottled inside for maybe
six to nine months and then i will just
explode over the smallest thing
how one i'm a two-parter
how did you first you know sort of
make a switch in your life and come in
to a close
personal touch with your own emotions
and you were able to vocalize them
because
i can't figure out how to do that do you
know what
i'm saying oh okay so what are the ways
that i can do that some girls journal
i love journaling i what i found is the
best
is um well there's tv
i need all of them okay okay so uh me
and my sister like if you guys can
like find like go on a hike or something
and find like a place that's like super
just like no one's around you yeah and
like you can either like scream really
loud which feels [ __ ] amazing
or like find like a stick and something
to hit and like hit it as hard as you
can
and like scream all the things whether
it be about yourself about to
given yet like whatever it is
and then let the promotions out or if
you like don't want to go that extreme
which like i
i don't like to i'm like oh like extreme
that was that was like not extreme for
me
this is why i was like this is gonna be
perfect for her
you um i i dance so like my sister
one time she cannot dance i can't dance
alexis i can't touch my toes like this
is okay
like what happens is like as females
we're like the life givers like
their life yes yeah our hips are
actually where we start most of our
trauma
and so much early yeah it's really
interesting and it's so so silly but uh
so my sister one time i was having the
worst day i don't know
i don't remember what it was and i was
like moping around i looked like a
[ __ ]
my sister looks at me and she's like i
know what to do
and she takes like the bluetooth and she
blasts shakira i'm like i don't want to
listen to security
she's like shake it out and she starts
twerking and i'm like
shake it out i like that shake it out
and so after about 30 minutes of her
coaxing me
and by the end of it we danced for an
hour and a half and like it
literally like he was like i'm shaking
out my emotions
everywhere like and and what you connect
to your femininity which is
super important and then you release
those emotions because you're
moving your your energy in motion in
that moment so like there's
i'm not i liked and those are also
active meditations as well like people
think that
you're gonna decision and standing still
it's not it's literally whatever gets
you in the present moment so like if it
stands is it writing
is it singing like whatever it is like
that and then
use that and know that that's a tool to
get out of that place
right okay i love that so i'll find my
tool we'll dance we'll hit things
well she's so jealous i love her on
dancing
that's such a good point wait okay so
wait wait wait wait i don't know wait i
could not get
back i i went to
when you were on was it two seasons ago
yeah maybe
yeah it does feel like a long time ago i
um had never been to a live taping of
the show
and for some reason i landed a ticket
and i saw
alexis run live ladies and gentlemen and
let me tell you
i was so impressed my mom and i were
like oh god
you were so good i don't know how you
didn't win i'm really confused
i'm really confused it was okay here's
another thing like
with that this is where my why comes
into place again this is why the y
weren't because like when they asked me
to be on dancing with the stars i was
like
that's just like that was my first
instinct seriously
but then i was like why would i do this
like i need a good reason to do this
otherwise like i'm not carrying myself
with my heart i'm carrying myself
yeah yeah yeah i get more publicity and
then i realized it was my mom's favorite
show in the world and i was like well
now i have to do it you have to do it
and so that's where that's why i came in
so that story actually
brought me to the finals because i was
so
honest with like the reason i was here
that people saw me
because at that time and people still
categorized me they were like those
sports little street model i was like
what's up
you know
you know it's just it's this it's this
story that we tell
when it comes to a pretty girl it's like
you can't yeah you can't have brains
you can't have a heart you can't help a
hundred percent
but i would like to say that you are
doing a really good job at separating
yourself from just one category
yeah you know what i mean you're not
just i don't look at alexis
it's hard but you you honestly you
fought your way to get out of that and
it it's because you're not just
alexis the tumblr brandy melville sports
illustrated model like you're so many
other things now
speaking of all your other things you're
also a singer
you've dabbled into acting that's part
of this you're here i was like what
so wait i wanna you basically you've
tackled nearly every career and you're
doing a really good job
it's almost like you can't not do
something but is there something that
you're hoping
a career that you haven't dabbled into
that you would love to try
like i do feel like there's this strong
thing in me being like
live as much as you can because my mom
didn't get to so like there's that deep
like i think
it really like pushes me to like just to
try everything
it's also the downside like even i was
talking to my policies and they're like
you jump around careers so much and i
was like
oh i know i get it but i like it because
my mom
tells us the same thing because we are
um we're always wanting to try different
things if something doesn't work we're
like
we're pivoting she says try
pivot like we love to pivot and it's
also for me like i've had two open-heart
surgeries so like i've had
like really major operations and so i've
kind of had this like new found of life
and she's always been like naturally
swipe i'm like i have to just like
write a book like try singing try acting
try this and
it's almost sometimes like i get so
wrapped up in doing almost
everything that i'm like i don't who am
i like what am i but then
you forgot like you're you're also not
your career like you don't have to base
who you are based on like
okay like when someone says like who are
you you don't say oh i'm a model you can
say
i want sophia i'm this or
who are you alexis like i need to like
why isn't even defining who you are by
your job like i think that's the coolest
thing about you is that like
if you're open or like old doesn't it
like the way that we identify ourselves
with our careers
like i want people to like instead of
what's your career what's your identity
like
right now like what are you doing yes
like i think that's so much cooler
um but yeah i love all of that all of
these things out of nowhere like
and it's interesting how you know as an
artist i'm sure you guys know it's like
i don't want to like create art when i'm
like super
stoked on life like it's only when i'm
like down and down i'm getting handled
and i'm hurtling and crying and i'm like
i need you i can't make the call
because i need to be sad right now to
write my music no i get it
yeah so that's like where it comes from
for me um
like acting prince for instance like
that's one that i want to go way deeper
into because i just love it so much i
think it's such like a spiritual
experience and
coming and being from la i didn't want
to act for so
long because everyone was an actress
yeah you're like
the barista is an actress and your
waiter's an actress and exactly
everyone's an actress i didn't want to
do it i was like no i didn't
um and because of that like just trying
to like stay away from
what everyone else was doing i didn't
actually see my like my love for it i
trained for a year
just like secretly because i wanted to
see like what it was about and i wanted
to like just hop over to different
techniques and see all the things
that i could use in my tool belt and i
just realized i was like
at the end of the day they're just
trying to bring us back to ourselves and
so if i can just stay
within myself yeah yeah circumstances
that
i'm given it's it's so much more than
just a job like you're healing yourself
through that role
and so for me it was like okay
that's what i want clearly but coming
into acting
as you know the sports illustrated model
um
the roles that i was getting it was very
like um
yeah there's no depth to work with and
so he was like
okay how can i create give this
character give this girl
the depth that you wouldn't expect from
this yeah and that's
that's the beautiful part about acting
because although you are reading someone
else's words it's really your inner
monologue your own dialogue that you're
saying through it and no one else has
that story but you so yeah and my dad
the best advice that he gives me it's
because i'm often like categorized to
only be like one
sort of actress and he always says you
know it only takes one yes
yeah one yes and that's that's all it
takes you're gonna do hundreds of
auditions
and you just need that one and so that's
i mean
i'm excited i i'm excited to see alexis
2021 on the big screen
i can't wait um sophia and i know we're
so excited for i'll be front row with my
popcorn
so she and i um sophie and i in the
beginning of this podcast
we're talking about um what our biggest
takeaway was from 2020 and what we want
to sort of like if we achieved a goal
that we'd wanted to or
what we're looking forward to in 2021
what would you say
that is for you i guess best thing i can
do for myself
is just to look back at 20 20 20 20 and
be like hmm
i actually did exactly whom i could have
done
which is like i made the best out of the
scenarios i
i created an opportunity from the
scenarios and then i helped people
in that so like that was a huge
with me so i think just once again like
like i guess
i i have a hard time patting myself in
the back because i'm always like running
ahead
so i'll do it for you good job
you feel good um and then i think for me
like what i would look forward to in
2021 is
i would just hope to like connect
connect deeper with the people who
know me and let them get to know me in a
way that feels
authentic and real um because i
i'm very um not like exhausted from
social media but like i'm really ready
to
like step into other things so that like
i can
feel in different ways what what were
you what was your guys's answers
yeah i learned how to say no
because i hate doing that
and i never have the balls to tell
someone what i want but they can tell me
exactly what they want me to do and i'll
just let them because
i don't know if i was shy or scared to
speak up for what i wanted but i learned
how to say no
and that is like the best word of 2020
for me
we need that we need more yeah we need
that um i think for
me it was starting to take
more control of my own life because i
felt like
i would always let people give me half
of them or half of what they could and i
wasn't giving fully that i'm like you
know what i'm gonna start asking for
what i want
i'm gonna start like if i'm a boss woman
i don't want people think oh like she's
just being over dramatic or
she's being that's like no i'm just
standing up just like a man would just
like anybody would in the position of
power
to own it and to show like this is what
i want this is how i want to do it and
start having more creative control and i
think 20 21 for all of us is going to be
really like it sounds like we're
probably
pretty much online but you really want
to grow the things that we've been
working on
yeah we really wanted to inspire yeah
and show it and like connect to people
that's why
we're doing the show this is why you're
doing warriors and you're using your
platform
and i just want to say like thank you so
much thank you for coming you are
genuinely
one of the most genuine people i've ever
met like you can just see
your kind and i wish we could give a
virtual hug
we should hang out because you we
clicked it right off the bat
yeah you were an amazing guy oh my god
you're awesome you're awesome of course
um but
please put your plug in for like
warriors so everyone can
get on that because it's amazing so
actually warriors um
is just launching i'm so so excited
it's like something we've been working
on for the last six months and it was a
dream that came to me during meditation
one day so i'm just really excited to
share it and grow it
um and then really grow this community
because i believe that community is
what's lacking in social media and i
hope to fill that gap
so the website is we are warriors.com
and i will be typing that in right after
this call i'm joining this community
we're joining the call
thank you
thank you so much for coming on wax
today i can't wait to hang out with you
once this pandemic is lifted well i know
that would be so fun
all right thank you so much guys bye
thank you
[Music]